[Music]
get ready for fire meet new merch alert
with crazy cool chest compressions
designed that's limited two weeks buy it
huge thank you to shipstation for
sponsoring this video
normal people instagram
facts on facts on facts on facts that's
not healthy the curves are there in your
spine for a reason when you over
accentuate them you actually create a
problem iron deficiency
oh my god
i would say that's an iron deficiency
man i would say this is like cactic iron
man
but i get the joke
made it medical for no reason doctor's
always ruining jokes high five fifty
percent less bacteria than a handshake
fist bump seventy eight percent less
bacteria than a handshake
sweep the leg 100 less bacteria than a
handshake
you think i'm gonna agree with this no
i'm not what is my man touching there
the floor do you know how gross the
floor is disgusting have you ever been
to a hospital the fluids the bacteria
the viruses the fungi the protozoa
do you even know what a protozoa is
feeling great since my kidney transplant
my kidney transplant
the kids knee transplant i never get the
ones with the knee disney
dasani
[Music]
when it's your first day at the
pediatric department
no why i may have done that my attending
who was teaching me that day was like
okay we're gonna start slow and i'm
gonna teach you the burrito roll where
they actually teach you how to burrito
roll the baby into the blanket in order
so the baby feels swaddled and
comfortable that was a fun trick to
learn because then i went into all the
rooms in the morning i was teaching the
parents as if i really knew what i was
doing
wow the covets out here are getting huge
oh my god when i was a kid i would throw
these at my friends all the time and get
them to stick to their hoodies and i
would get in trouble because the
teacher's like oh my god you might hit
an eye and they were right but i was a
bad kid i like how when a doctor pulls
some medicine into a syringe they squirt
a little in the air for their fall
it's like now what we're doing is we're
trying to get the air bubbles out if you
inject too much air into someone's
bloodstream you could actually get an
air embolism huge problem it could be
lethal but still we like to get it out
and make sure that we're flush mito corn
why don't corn jerry og this is really
great because mitochondria kind of does
look like a corn dog it also looks like
a regular just like hot dog skeleton
parts identified but
if you were anybody in the human body
comment down below i asked us on twitter
i got weird responses medical alphabet
this is what they teach us in med school
by the way confuse the lawyers so they
can't go after you because if they say
that you didn't write something you
could just point to a scribble and be
like what do you think this is doctor i
have your diagnosis me make it quick i
don't have much time doctor who told you
[Laughter]
that's sad how coffee works coffee
magic
energy oh my god am i going to really
have to go into the nerdy explanation of
why coffee works not gonna do that i'm
just gonna laugh at this meme
what a terrible gift john cena surprised
a seven-year-old boy with cancer on his
birthday what oh
the importance of gram gr grammar i
forgot what the importance of grandpa
commas being get your flu shot now
available in pumpkin spice
if we want vaccine acceptance to go sky
high you throw that in a gucci vial you
know influencers are coming up and then
when that gets old you do the gucci
supreme collab yo that's gonna be hot
back to the memes in just a second but
first i want to talk to you about ship
station look if you ever had to ship
anything before i don't need to tell you
how frustrating it can be but thanks to
shipstation shipping will become the
easiest part of your online business its
order management and shipping software
is designed to make your life
hassle-free which will really come in
handy this holiday season from the
dashboard you could easily import orders
from amazon ebay etsy even your own
website and automate just about every
shipping task they work with
international and local shipping
companies around the world like fedex
and ups and you even get access to
discounted rates that are usually
reserved for fortune 500 companies 98 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it for as long as
they're in business and with more people
shopping online this holiday season
you'll want help making your orders
stress free just go to shipstation.com
dr mike remember doctors spelled out to
get a 60-day free trial now all right
let's get back to the memes it looked
like she needs a crown i know right yes
queen slay
that's funny all my dentists out there
what's up you want a box for those sir
now i hate violence is it cool if i just
paid my card yeah i'll box for those as
some of you may know i've been boxing
lately i've been getting some
challengers coming my way but i want
more so if you want to box me i'm like
195 pounds six foot three you want to do
it
hmu who says hmu boomer you're in rare
form i'm i'm in boomer forever i'm
really dying doctor your dad's not with
us anymore me damn doctor he's at a
different hospital me okay doctor
no that's not what we do and this guy
does not look like a real doctor because
he has a shirt buttoned all the way up
but he doesn't have a tie i'm not sure
what's going on there doctor you need
surgery in this section it's probably
best to remove the whole spine woman why
doctor it's just holding you back
no you you you kind of need the spine
it's supportive
great hike you lost 159 pounds
or what oh the bear oh my god bear would
you ever do that
bears down here he wouldn't do that to
mike's dismay it turned out that bear
was in fact not there
[Music]
would you like a drink what are my
options yes sir
this like sparked a memory when we were
first coming to america none of us spoke
english they were asking me if i'd like
a drink and i didn't know what the
questions meant and i was like maybe and
the lady was so confused so my sister
was like he wants a coke as a
six-year-old i wasn't that wise what
inspired you to go into family medicine
oh i'm excited to read the bottom hello
i hate money i love burnout excuse me
family medicine doctors can still make a
great living and we burn out we do burn
out this machine turns stress into a
visible light
i am the sun not all stress is bad
stress overcoming short-term stress is
positive because we learn from it and
prepare for the real world which carries
stress inherently with it what we don't
like is chronic stress that serves no
benefit and we learn to live with the
stresses that we cannot control
buddhist mentality i don't know why i
did this she wanted peace sanctuary i'm
afraid there was a mix-up i was supposed
to amputate your left leg
why is the doctor saying that oh the
doctors have mutated their own left leg
honestly at this point how burned out we
are not surprising i also like don't
know why there's snakes coming out of
that patient monitor
when your chest starts hurting and you
hit the spot where it's hurting and it
stops help
help help heal
me working on notes i can't keep doing
this forever honestly i relate to that
like crazy it's been 20 seconds
for some reason when i start doing notes
i do one note enjoying the dopamine rush
so much that i pick up my phone i'm like
forget these
when you look better in scrubs than you
do in the clubs
facts professional rappers the guy who
says the side effects
of a medicine in an ad you ever hear the
side effects not an ad on tv but an ad
on the radio
it's literally like the substantial side
effects of the lung cancer containing
carcinogens that are affecting your
brain waves are gonna one time
trying to be an adult and read a
scientific paper and your wife does this
harry potter and that's funny though
chest compressions chest compression
chest compressions chest compress
what do you think about my shirt though
you want it you can get it
it's right there 48 hour protection my
deodorant the doctor saying i have 24
hours left to live well the deodorant's
really going to give you the bang for
for the buck
the deodorant is going to give you a
good bang for the buck i don't know what
i'm trying to say here i'm gonna have
some water
i have three plants that are flourishing
and one that's dying i don't know what i
did wrong to the one that's dying
oh that's so good whoever created that
that was an old fake plant that used to
be in my videos in my previous apartment
and that plant that is forever
immortalized oh yeah
that's the plan
well that's not their plan that's a
replica of the plant made by the patreon
community if you want to join you get
access to our discord monthly live
streams all that good stuff links down
below silica gel do not eat oh my god
those silica packets i have some kind of
fear that i'm gonna drop it and bear's
gonna munch on it congratulations you
escaped the simulation okay we're gonna
have a serious conversation don't do
this
don't eat the silica gel packets if you
want to continue being happy and healthy
you shouldn't eat them perfect tinder
profile doesn't exist i'm dying to meet
you when can i see
those guys dms are probably exploding
right now swipe right you will die by 20
55. i still have a lot of time to go to
school marry and have a job oh you're
saying it in military time oh my god
it's so evil and the doctors are always
[Music]
medical show accuracy doctor mike
no lie i'm coming for you i don't care
if you're a big show small show i'm
coming removing the scab on your wound
your blood platelets that have been
working for days why peel the scab
people do that a lot and they think
drying out the wound is better nope
keeping it covered in moist is better
what part of the body always loses
the colon defeat
they always get me do you want to see
defeat
should i make an only fan
prevent carpal tunnel no slouch
shoulders bent wrists
yes running into woods never to be seen
again honestly quite accurate you want
to avoid pressure on the flexor
retinaculum here which is the fibrous
band that sits at the edge of your wrist
that keeps the median nerve protected
and tight i made this into an
educational thing they were talking
about bears or something
sorry need books no worries donate
plasma me i cannot afford tuition united
states then pay with your blood we had
someone on our youtube channel not too
long ago on a plasma video say that they
did this a lot through college in order
to make some extra money on the side
united states is one of a few countries
that allows companies to pay for your
plasma but it's all going to a good
purpose so i don't mind that who did it
better
no lie i think mine's better mine's real
pikachu fake this guy acting me legit
above knee
bony okay
i get it i get you're trying to get me
with the knee things all this and me if
that's a tattoo that someone got though
you're putting your body on the line for
humor i got ants yeah but my ants are
taller than yours yeah well i got a tube
of glue
and i have an entire tin of it
i got bread ah you win i can't handle
that with my gluten and taller ants
[Music]
i i think i need to be either drunk to
read this
can't handle that with my gluten
intolerance
stop laughing sadnesses
are they ants on something
do the items have a connection
bison kit
let me know when you need a lifeline i
can't handle that with my gluten and
taller ants
i can't i give up what is it okay um who
can't eat bread
uh celiac because he like people are
because they have
inflammation
i don't know what's the question we're
so close bread contains wheat you can't
eat bread because it contains
gluten
okay yeah ah you win i can't handle that
with my gluten
and tolerance intolerance
who came up with that there's no normal
person that's thinking about ants glue
and bread
reacting to viral surgery videos here
including michael reeves surgical robot
crazy click here to check that out and
huge thank you to ship station for
sponsoring this video as always stay
happy and stay healthy
[Music]